♪ ♪
>> Dana: PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
NANCY PELOSI ENGAGING IN SOME
HEATED PERSONAL ATTACKS, TRADING
SHOTS ALL WEEKEND.
IF THE SPEAKER BLASTING TRUMP’S
RESPONSE TO THE OUTBREAK.
SPEAK OF THE PRESIDENT HAS MADE
MANY MISTAKES.
LEADERS TAKE RESPONSIBILITY.
SO FOR A WEAK LEADER WHO DOES
NOT TAKE RESPONSIBILITY, HE
PLACES BLAME ON OTHERS.
AND THAT MIGHT’VE BEEN OKAY FOR
BEFORE, BUT WE CANNOT CONTINUE
DOWN A PATH THAT IS AGAIN A
COMBATING WITH SCIENCE, SCIENCE,
SCIENCE.
EVIDENCE, DATA ON HOW WE CAN GO
FORWARD.
>> Dana: TRUMP AND PELOSI
CLASHING OVER FUNDING TO HELP
SMALL BUSINESSES, REPUBLICANS
LASHING OUT AT DEMOCRATS OVER
DELAYS BECAUSE FUNDING FOR THE
PROGRAM RAN OUT LAST WEEK.
AFTER AN IMPASSE, IT LOOKS LIKE
THE WHITE HOUSE AND CONGRESS ARE
CLOSE ON A $470 BILLION PACKAGE
TO HELP SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP WEIGHED IN ON
THAT.
>> YOU SAY IT IS READY TO GO,
THEN THEY SAY, WE HAVE A GOOD
NEGOTIATING SYSTEM, BECAUSE HE
SAID IT WAS READY TO GO.
WE ARE NEGOTIATING WITH THE
DEMOCRATS, AND THEY NEGOTIATE
THE THINGS THAT WE CAN DO THAT
WE DON’T THINK ARE IN THE BEST
INTERESTS OF THE PEOPLE OF THIS
COUNTRY.
WE ARE VERY CLOSE TO A DEAL.
>> Dana: I’M GOING TO GO TO
YOU FIRST ON THIS, BECAUSE I
WANT TO POINT OUT THAT IT IS
LIKELY THAT WHAT EVER THEY PASS
IS GOING TO LOOK ALMOST
IDENTICAL TO WHAT THEY HAD
PROPOSED TWO WEEKS AGO.
SO THIS MONEY DID NOT ACTUALLY
HAVE TO RUN OUT, IT WAS JUST
PLAYING POLITICS WITH IT, AND I
HAVE SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS WHO
HAVE APPLIED, AND THEY CAN’T GET
THEIR MONEY.
AND EVERY DAY THEY ARE THINKING
THEY ARE GOING TO HAVE TO LAY
OFF OR THEY ARE GOING TO LAY OFF
PEOPLE OR THEY ARE GOING TO HAVE
TO LOSE THEIR BUSINESS.
>> Dagen: THESE ARE FAMILY
BUSINESSES THAT ARE FLAT ON
THEIR BACKS.
AND THESE PEOPLE DON’T KNOW HOW
THEY ARE GOING TO STAY OPEN.
BECAUSE THE DEMOCRATS WERE
PLAYING POLITICS WITH A RELOAD
AND A REFRESHING AND A REFILL OF
THE SMALL BUSINESS PAYCHECK
PROTECTION PROGRAM.
SEVEN DAYS BEFORE THAT PROGRAM
RAN OUT OF MONEY,
MITCH McCONNELL PUT IN FRONT
OF THE DEMOCRATS A 25-LINE BILL
JUST FOR THE MONEY.
AND WHAT DID THEY DO?
THEY DRAG TO THEIR FEET.
SO EVERY TIME ANYONE OF THESE
DEMOCRATS EVER SAYS SMALL
BUSINESSES.
SO THEY FIGURE OUT THE FABRIC OF
AMERICA, THEY COULD BE PROCEEDED
WITH THE GO TO HELL, SMALL
BUSINESSES, BECAUSE THAT’S WHAT
YOU DID.
AND NOW THEY ARE TRYING TO TURN
IT ON THE REPUBLICANS -- THE
DEMOCRATS ARE, WHY DID THE BLUE
STATES NOT GET AS MANY LOANS
FILLED AS SOME OF THE RED
STATES?
BECAUSE THAT’S WHERE THE BIG
BANKS WERE, AND THEY DESERVE ALL
LOT OF THE BIG BANKS.
BUT MAKING ABOUT $120 BILLION IN
LOANS OUT OF A $350 BILLION
PROGRAM.
THOSE BIG BANKS,
BANK OF AMERICA, JPMORGAN, THEY
SLOWLY WALKED FOR THE FIRST TEN
DAYS OF THE PROGRAM WHEN THEY
SHOULD’VE BEEN STEPPING UP LIKE
THE COMMUNITY BANKS.
THERE IS SHAME TO GO AROUND.
AND I HAVE A STEAMING PILE OF
HORSE MANURE THEY CAN ALL JUMP
IN.
>> Greg: YEAH.
>> Dana: I KNEW THAT I WANTED
TO GO TO YOU FIRST ON THAT.
GREG, WHAT ABOUT THE VIEW
BETWEEN PELOSI AND TRUMP?
GOING THROUGH A EMERGENCY AND A
PANDEMIC AND AN ELECTION YEAR.
>> Greg: I HATE IT WHEN
POLITICS INTRUDES.
BUT FIRST I WANT TO ADDRESS THE
SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS THAT ARE
BEING IGNORED.
THERE ARE A LOT OF SOLE
PROPRIETORS AND 1099 ON SALARY
WORKERS THAT ARE BEING TURNED
DOWN BY BANKS AS WELL.
SO RESTAURANTS, HOSPITALITY
SECTORS, THEY EMPLOY A LOT OF
NONSALARY WORKERS.
AND THEY ARE NOT GETTING ANY
HELP FROM THE BANKS ON THAT,
BECAUSE THEY DON’T ACCEPT 1099.
THAT NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED.
BUT TO THE FEUD, WE LEARNED IN
TIMES OF VIRUS THAT POLITICS IS
INCURABLE.
AND IT HAS A CHIEF SYMPTOM OF
AMNESIA WHERE IT ALLOWS PEOPLE
TO ACCUSE OTHERS OF SIN THAT
THEY JUST COMMITTED.
LIKE PELOSI OR de BLASIO, OR
CUOMO, WHO SAID PEOPLE SHOULD
JUST KEEP GOING TO MASS EVENTS,
SO THEY REALLY CAN’T CRITICIZE
TRUMP ABOUT DELAY, SINCE THEY
ARE TELLING PEOPLE IT WAS NO BIG
DEAL.
IT WASN’T PELOSI FOCUSING ON THE
EXAGGERATED HYSTERIA OF LABOR
DATES BEFORE SHE GOT AROUND TO
THIS?
BY THE WAY, EVERYONE DO
THEMSELVES A FAVOR, GOOGLE DAN
CRENSHAW ON BILL MAHER, IT IS
THE BEST.
>> Dana: YES, YES, YOU SHOULD
DO THAT AND SPEND SOME TIME
WITHOUT ONE.
BUT THE SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS,
LIKE RESTAURANTS, THEY HAVE
THEIR RENT THAT THEY HAVE TO PAY
TO THE LANDLORD.
AND THEY ARE NOT SURE IF THEY
ARE GOING TO BE ABLE TO MAKE IT
MUCH LONGER.
>> Jesse: COULD YOU IMAGINE,
DANA, IF THERE WAS A REPUBLICAN
IN CHARGE AND THAT REPUBLICAN
WAS HOLDING UP MONEY TO SMALL
BUSINESSES, TO FAMILIES IN THE
MIDDLE OF AN ECONOMIC CALAMITY?
THE MEDIA WOULD BE BREATHING
FIRE, BUT FOR SOME REASON
NANCY PELOSI GETS A PASS.
I CANNOT BELIEVE THAT SHE SAYS
THAT TRUMP BUMBLED THE THING,
THAT MUST MEAN THAT FAUCI AND
BIRX FUMBLED IT, BECAUSE EVERY
TIME THEY CAME WITH A
RECOMMENDATION, HE ACTED
IMMEDIATELY ON IT.
I MEAN, IT WAS MARCH 16TH THAT
THEY SAID, SHUT THIS DOWN.
TRUMP SHUTS IT DOWN.
YOU KNOW HOW MANY DEATHS THERE
WERE?
FIVE DOZEN.
IF NANCY KNEW ON MARCH 16TH THAT
WE SHOULD’VE SHUT IT DOWN TO
WEEKS EARLIER, WHY DID SHE NOT
GET ON THE HORN WITH FAUCI AND
BIRX AND SAY, YOU ARE TOO LATE.
BECAUSE ON MARCH 1ST THERE WAS
ONE DEATH, AND IF MASTER THOMAS
NANCY KNEW AFTER ONE DEATH ON
MARCH 1ST THAT WE NEED TO SHOUT
TO THE GREATEST ECONOMY DOWN,
WELL, THEN MY GOD, SHE IS IN THE
WRONG LINE OF BUSINESS.
BECAUSE NO ONE KNEW AT THAT
POINT, THE EUROPEANS HAD NOT
SHUT ANYTHING DOWN, NO ONE KNEW
A THING.
AND I HAD OUR RESEARCHERS CHECK
TO SEE IF NANCY PELOSI HAD
POINTED A FINGER AT CHINA OR THE
W.H.O.?
GUESS HOW MANY INSTANCES THEY
FOUND?
ZERO.
THAT SAYS A LOT ABOUT NANCY.
MAYBE SHE IS COLLUDING WITH THE
CHINESE?
MAYBE WE SHOULD WIRETAP HER?
>> Dana: LET ME GET JUAN IN
HERE.
WE’LL TALK ABOUT THE CHINESE AND
THE REPUBLICANS IN THE DEMOCRATS
WHEN WE GET INTO THE NEXT BLOCK.
BUT DO YOU THINK CONGRESS SHOULD
RESPOND ABOUT COMING BACK TO
WASHINGTON TO WORK THESE THINGS
OUT IN A QUICKER WAY?
>> Juan: SURE.
AND I THINK THAT SPEAKER --
MAJORITY LEADER, SAID WE NEED TO
GET THIS DONE.
AND HE IS GOING TO OPEN THE
SENATE AT 4:00 TO GET IN A VOTE,
BUT THEY COULD NOT GET ANYTHING
IN PLACE TODAY.
BUT THEY NEED TO GET IT DONE.
BUT TO YOUR POINT INTO THE OTHER
POINT, LISTEN, I THINK DEMOCRATS
ARE ADVOCATING THAT THE MONEY
NEEDS TO GO TO REGULAR FOLKS.
TO THE PEOPLE.
TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
AND NOT THROUGH THE JPMORGANS
AND END UP IN THE PLANS OF BLUE
CHRIS STEAK HOUSE, BECAUSE EVEN
THOUGH IT IS A BIG COMPANY AND
INDIVIDUAL FRANCHISES APPLY, BUT
THEY GET THE BIG PAYCHECK, AND
THEY SAY, THIS BACKLASH COMING
AT US, WE HAVE TO GIVE SOME OF
THE MONEY.
I THINK THEY GAVE ALL THE MONEY
BACK THAT THEY WERE GETTING.
>> Dana: THEY DID.
THEY GAVE THEIR LOAN BACK.
>> Juan: WHAT YOU NEED A
SMALLER BANKS, AND I THINK
THAT’S PART OF WHAT
CHUCK SCHUMER AND THE DEMOCRATS
WANT TO.
YOU WANT SMALLER BANKS THAT DO
COMMUNITY BANKING THAT TO REACH
OUT TO SMALL BUSINESSES AND
LOCALITIES, BOTH URBAN AND
RURAL, AND TO SMALLER NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS TO MAKE SURE THEY
GET A FAIR SHARE OF THE MONEY.
AND IT DOES NOT SIMPLY GO TO
PEOPLE THAT ARE POLITICALLY
CONNECTED AT THE VERY TOP, NOT
ONLY IN TERMS OF WASHINGTON, BUT
IN TERMS OF THE BIG BANKS.
THAT’S NOT FAIR.
>> Dana: I DON’T KNOW IF YOU
HEARD THAT TRAIN WHISTLE, BUT --
THE TRAIN WHISTLE MEANS WE GOT